lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
calcular una medida típica sobre qué
también coinciden los datos reales con
un modelo en este caso un modelo lineal
hay varios nombres para esto podríamos
considerarlo la desviación estándar de
los residuos que es en esencia lo que
vamos a calcular también le podemos
llamar raíz del error cuadrática medio
que describe cómo lo calculamos lo que
vamos a hacer es observar los residuos
de cada uno de estos puntos y después
encontraremos la desviación estándar de
ellos como repaso recordemos que el yeso
residuo es igual al décimo para cierta x
menos el valor de predicho para cierta x
ésta llegue con sombrero nos va a decir
cuál será la regresión lineal predicha
para una x dada y esta es la ye real
para cierta x esto es sólo un repaso
pues ya hemos hecho esto en vídeos
anteriores en este punto de aquí cuando
x es igual a 1 la aie es igual a 1 pero
el modelo predice 2.5 por uno a menos 2
es 0.5 nuestro residuo es un 0.5 que es
igual a 0.5 y es un 0.5 positivo si el
punto real se encuentra por arriba del
modelo el residuo será positivo en el
punto de aquí arriba también tenemos el
punto por arriba del modelo lo que nos
dará un residuo positivo cuando x es
igual a 3 la real es 6 pero el modelo
predice 2.5 por 3 es 7.5 menos 2 nos da
5.56 menos 5.5 nos da 0.5 de nuevo
tenemos un residuo positivo para el
punto que coincide justo con el modelo
el valor real es el valor predicho así
que no tenemos residuo aquí cuando x es
igual a 2 que es igual a 3 el modelo
predice 3 por lo que el residuo es 3
menos 3 igual a 0 y para nuestro último
punto el residuo será igual al valor
real
x2 y es 2 - el valor predicho cuando x
es igual a 2 el modelo predice 2.5 por
25 menos 2 es igual a 32 menos 3 es
igual a menos 1 cuando el valor real
está por debajo de la recta de regresión
nuestro residuo es negativo ahora
podemos calcular la desviación estándar
de los residuos tomamos el primer
residuo que es 0.5 lo elevamos al
cuadrado y le sumamos el segundo residuo
que es 0 y lo elevamos al cuadrado ahora
tenemos el tercer residuo que es menos 1
y lo elevamos al cuadrado finalmente
tenemos el último residuo que es 0.5 así
que sumamos 0.5 al cuadrado tomamos
todos los residuos que podemos ver como
la diferencia entre el valor real y el
valor predicho por el modelo los
elevamos al cuadrado y los sumamos para
calcular una desviación estándar típica
tomamos la diferencia entre el valor y
la media aquí
la diferencia entre el valor del punto y
el valor que predice el modelo elevamos
al cuadrado cada residuo y lo sumamos y
de la misma forma que calculamos la
desviación estándar vamos a dividir
entre la cantidad de residuos que
tenemos menos uno si tenemos cuatro
residuos lo vamos a dividir entre cuatro
menos uno igual a tres podemos ver esto
como la media de los errores al cuadrado
y ahora calculemos la raíz cuadrada de
esto esto es igual a la raíz cuadrada de
0.5 al cuadrado es 0.25 + 0 al cuadrado
es 0 + menos 1 al cuadrado nos da 1 +
0.5 al cuadrado que nos da 0.25 todo
esto entre 3 nos queda 1.5 entre 31.5 es
exactamente la mitad de 3 por lo que
esto es un medio nos queda la raíz
cuadrada de un medio que es igual a 1
entre la raíz cuadrada de 2 sacamos la
calculadora 1 entre la raíz cuadrada de
y redondeamos esto a la milésima más
cercana nos da aproximadamente 0 puntos
707 lo escribimos
si queremos visualizar esto una
desviación estándar por debajo de la
recta luce así y una desviación estándar
por arriba de la recta para cualquier
valor de x luce así noten que esta
aproximación está hecha a mano no es muy
exacta pero pueden ver que esto es un
indicador aproximado del residuo típico
observemos que algunas personas se
refieren a esto como el residuo promedio
pero depende de como interpreten ustedes
la palabra promedio porque aquí estamos
elevando al cuadrado los residuos así
que los valores atípicos los puntos que
se encuentren realmente lejos de la
recta cuando los elevamos al cuadrado
tendrán un impacto desproporcionado aquí
si no queremos tener este comportamiento
podemos encontrar la media de los
residuos absolutos que puede ser algo
más sencillo pero esta es una forma
estándar de como las personas pueden ver
si un modelo coincide con los datos
reales pueden imaginar que mientras más
pequeño sea este número el modelo se
ajustará mejor a los
datos